les chefs d'état disposant de leur
propre industrie automobile m à utiliser
des voitures de luxe produite dans leur
propre pays c'est une règle tacite pour
les événements officiels la voiture du
chef de l'état n'est pas seulement un
symbole de la prospérité de la nation
c'est aussi une question de prestige
national
joe biden utilise une limousine cadillac
one surnommé the beast à la carrosserie
blindé et qui pèse 10 tonnes
boris johnson se fait conduire dans une
jaguar la reine elizabeth 2 à une
bentley la chancelière allemande angela
merkel avait choisi nos 10 et le
président français manuel macron roule
dans une citroën ds 7
en russie la fabrication de voitures de
cette classe a été suspendu il ya plus
de vingt ans il a fallu cinq ans pour
rattraper ce retard sur l'industrie
automobile mondiale de la planche à
dessin au premier modèle achevé
voilà le russe joyau de l'industrie
automobile russe
[Musique]
les véhicules des chefs d'état ont
toujours été une priorité absolue la
première voiture haut de gamme utilisés
par un empereur russe nicolas deux
étaient là delaunay belleville française
lénine chef du prolétariat mondial m et
les voitures anglaises
ce modèle unique au monde réalisé à
partir d'une rolls royce était adaptée
pour circuler sur des terrains
accidentés dans des conditions
difficiles quant à staline l'une de ces
voitures blindées préféré était une pas
card américaine qui pouvait protéger
contre d'éventuelles tentatives
d'assassinât il y a roulé jusqu'à la fin
des années 40 lorsque l'urss a commencé
à produire son équivalent l'asie 115
blindés le dirigeant soviétique suivant
nikita khrouchtchev croyait fermement
que les gens l'aimaient il n'utilisait
donc pas de véhicules blindés et a pris
goût aux cabriolets soviétique les
dirigeants soviétiques ont dû revenir
aux voitures blindées après une
tentative d'assassinât ratée contre
leonid brejnev en janvier 1969
la dernière ils à avoir transporté des
chefs d'état est passée du président de
l'union soviétique mikhaïl gorbatchev au
président de la russie boris elstine
l'urss a cessé d'exister l'économie du
pays s'est effondré ce fut un coup dur
pour toutes les industries et la
construction automobile n'a pas fait
exception le président russe boris
eltsine a choisi une mercedes et
vladimir poutine utilisait la même
voiture jusqu'à ce que toutes les pièces
du puzzle soit assemblé en russie
le financement la technologie est encore
plus important les personnes capables de
se charger d'un projet aussi ambitieux
le principal initiateur a été notre
président qui a convoqué le ministre de
l'industrie et du commerce en 2012 et a
dit qu'il était temps de créer notre
propre voiture basée sur une plateforme
modulaire unifiée
c'est l'idée qui était au coeur de ce
projet
la plateforme modulaire dit unifié est
une nouvelle gamme de véhicules de
prestige elle permet aussi de créer une
berline une fourgonnette et une
décapotable elles sont configurés pour
répondre aux exigences spécifiques des
clients mais partagent la même
conception technologique de base
l'objectif consistait à créer une
voiture aux fonctionnalités qui
répondrait aux exigences particulières
du garage présidentielle il s'agit de
fonctionnalités très spécifique mais
devait aussi satisfaire les besoins des
acheteurs de voitures de luxe sur le
marché
ce n'est pas seulement une voiture
présidentielle c'est une voiture qui a
donné vie à toute une gamme de modèles
et qui plus est à des technologies
le projet cortège a été confiée au nani
l'institut central de recherche
scientifique et automobile qui a
développé la toute première automobile
soviétique mais après la pérestroïka le
namy n'était tout simplement pas à la
hauteur de la tâche pour entreprendre un
projet d'une telle envergure dans les
années 90 c'était un désastre presque
toutes les personnes talentueuses avait
quitté le pays ou changer de métier et
ne sont plus revenus dans l'industrie
l'institut n'était pas encore mort mais
il vivait à peine
en premier le défend les machines-outils
avaient en moyenne 45 ans dont la
toiture fuyez
et soudain on nous a confié la tâche de
créer une bentley presque à partir de
zéro
environ 500 à 600 personnes travaillent
ici je pense l'âge moyen des employés
étaient bien au delà des 60 ans c'est
dès que le projet a été lancé nous avons
commencé à monter une nouvelle équipe
on cherchait des spécialistes
expérimentés de la vieille école
soviétique certains ont refusé il y
avait beaucoup de sceptiques au début il
y avait aussi des jeunes spécialistes ou
faisait d'abord passer un test à la
personne pour comprendre ce dont elle
était capable c'est comme ça que nous
avons formé notre équipe
s'est institué à rassembler la masse
critique de gens qui savaient comment la
fabriquer et encore plus important
qu'ils voulaient faire ce projet
[Musique]
la plupart des gens n'ont aucune idée de
comment créer une voiture tout le monde
pense qu'un ingénieur prend un crayon se
met devant sa planche à dessin et
commence à dessiner la première pièce en
fait tout commence avec le marketing pas
avec la conception quand je suis venu
travailler un ami il n'y avait même pas
de département marketing à l'époque
soviétique leur travail était basée sur
des caractéristiques techniques définies
dans un cahier de charges qu'il devait
strictement respectées mais dans notre
cas l'accent est mis sur la
commercialisation de la voiture
aujourd'hui en marketing on trouve un
public ciblé on découvre ce qu'il veut
on rédige une liste de fonctionnalités
qui est ensuite transmise aux ingénieurs
aux concepteurs sous changement non
vérifiés au préalable pourrait impliquer
des coûts importants si l'utilisateur
dit non non ça ne va pas vous serez
obligé de recommencer ce qui demande du
temps et de l'argent le premier défi
était de proposer une fonctionnalité un
détail qui distinguerait cette voiture
de toutes les autres et qui ferait
clairement référence aux pays d'origine
élément principal était une énorme
calandre autour de laquelle le reste de
la conception a été envisagée nous avons
repris l'idée de l'asie ce sont dix la
première voiture haut de gamme produite
en union soviétique
s'est inspirée d'elle pour les premiers
croquis
cette voiture avait un long capot que
l'on appelle ici l'espace de prestige
c'est à dire une grande distance entre
le pied du pare brise et lax des roues
avant plus cette distance est grande
plus la voiture est cher en plus son
statut prestigieux et lorsque les
concepteurs et les ingénieurs se sont
mis à travailler la voiture a commencé à
changer on était horrifiée elle
ressemblait à une sorte d'hippopotames à
quelque chose de disgracieux parce que
la plateforme modulaire et la
configuration ne permettait pas de
conserver de bonnes proportions
il ya eu des débats animés lors des
réunions les designers blâmer les
ingénieurs et vice versa les ingénieurs
voulait rester fidèle à la technologie
est assurée la simplicité du système et
les designers se concentre uniquement
sur le style c'est une contradiction
éternelle si c'est beau cela ne peut pas
être en même temps avancé
technologiquement et l'inversé est aussi
vrai ce qui est trop simple n'est pas
toujours beau puis le marketing a
proposé de passer une procédure appelée
kerkini kerlink
ça nous prenons la toute première
version ce cas il s'agissait d'un modèle
grandeur nature de la voiture en mousse
de polyuréthane de la styromousse sur ou
en fait je chante on nous y avons collé
des vitres l'avant points avec de la
peinture automobile pour que cela
ressemble à une voiture entièrement
terminée
nous avons recueilli les opinions des
gens qui utilisent des voitures de ce
type des véhicules de première classe
très cher
60 propriétaires de rolls royce et de
bâcler chacun est entrée dans la pièce
où notre modèle se trouvait avec nos
concurrents à gauche et à droite alors
demandé s'il aimait la voiture comment
il évalué ce qui ne les met pas et tout
cela était enregistrée
les commentaires sur l'apparence étaient
dévastateurs
ils ont dit que cela avait l'air démodé
trop simple bonjour et comment cela nous
avons bien discuté et décidé que c'était
pas mal
les non spécialistes qu'il a volé pour
la première fois donné généralement d
opinion très négative sur ce que nous
avions fait
nous les designers avons raflé encore
200 mm aux ingénieurs de sorte que le
capot est devenu plus long pour que la
voiture soit spécial je dirais même pour
qu'elle ait une apparence russe
nous demande parfois ce qu'il ya deux
russes dans ce design voilà quand les
designers et les ingénieurs se battre
les uns contre les autres le résultat
est que la voiture commence à ressembler
un véhicule russe
les lignes horizontales rendre l'objet
plus dynamiques tandis que les lignes
verticales lui donne un air prestigieux
puissant et solide
si vous regardez notre voiture vous
verrez des similitudes avec la colonnade
d'un bâtiment fiables et sérieux que
rien ne peut détériorer au faire bouger
la deuxième procédure de cas cliniques
et effectuer une fois à l'intérieur du
véhicule terminé la troisième lorsque le
véhicule est prête à rouler
nous préparons la voiture étape par
étape pour qu'elle puisse répondre à
tous les souhaits de notre public cible
une fois qu'elle est entrée sur le
marché
maintenant que tout est clair quant à
l'extérieur qui at il sous le capot à
quels critères la meilleure des
automobiles doit-elle répondre de ce qui
colle ces listings nous rédigeons un
document portant sur les
caractéristiques d'une voiture potentiel
c'est le catalogue de fonctionnalités
clés il contient environ 500 articles si
vous écrivant par exemple douceur de
roulement sur les pavés et en précise si
ça doit être mieux que chez nos
concurrents équivalent ta que si ce
n'est pas important quand on a parfois
l'impression qu'il faut tout faire mieux
que les autres et construire un véhicule
idéal mais si la voiture est la
meilleure sur tous les plans elle sera
dix fois plus onéreuse que celle de vos
concurrents par exemple en ce qui
concerne le roulement en douceur on l'a
mis sur la liste est marquée comme
devant être le meilleur car notre
voiture est fait pour les passagers à
l'arrière mais pour la maniabilité nous
écrivons moyenne au lieu de devant être
la meilleure car le propriétaire sur la
banquette arrière n'appréciera pas une
maniabilité réactive 106 les cent 100
points sont classées est passé aux
concepteurs et aux ingénieurs qui
commence à fabriquer une voiture qui
correspond à ses spécificités
nos concurrents prennent toujours la
génération précédente de modèles comme
base lors de la conception de nouveaux
véhicules
notre projet est unique en ce sens qu'il
est essentiellement parti de zéro
bien sûr nous utilisons des petits
éléments standardisés qui sont
compatibles avec de nombreuses voitures
modernes
mais tout le reste les systèmes les
sous-systèmes les pièces sont conçus
spécifiquement pour notre projet
le volume de travail est colossal
beaucoup plus important que chez des
constructeurs automobiles
traditionnelles lorsqu'il passe d'un
modèle à un autre
le travail était déjà en cours quand la
situation internationale a brusquement
changé
les tensions est ouest qui sont apparus
en 2014 ont rompu les liens économiques
qui semblait durable
peu de gens croyaient au projet surtout
parmi ceux qui n'en faisait pas partie
il pensait que ça ne marcherait pas même
nos fournisseurs étaient de cet avis
ils devront ce succès à nos compétences
en impression 3d
historiquement nous sommes parmi les
premiers dans le pays à maîtriser cette
technologie
cela permet de réduire considérablement
le temps de production des prototypes de
voitures
les premiers prototypes de tout
l'intérieur du système de climatisation
et de nombreuses pièces ont été imprimés
en 3d
nous avons l'une des meilleures fonderie
moderne de matériaux non ferreux
le chef d'atelier de la métallurgie et
les ouvriers de la fonderie effectué
ensemble un travail difficile de haute
qualité
en revanche en termes d'usinage nous
disposons d'une excellente base
manufacturière
on a des infrastructures de production
très bien équipée avec beaucoup de
machines outils modernes
le plus important ce sont les opérateurs
mécaniciens les ingénieurs il n'y a
aucun problème technologique qu'ils ne
peuvent résoudre
quand nous avons voulu visiter bentley
et rolls royce ils ont refusé arguant
que nous étions leurs concurrents cela
nous a fait sourire nous aussi
mais ils comprennent bien que tout
change rapidement et bien il semble que
les russes fabrique une voiture ce sera
amusant de voir ce qu'ils pourront faire
tout le monde se développe si vous
n'arrêtez pas vous créerez un produit
réinventer l'automobile pour inventer
quelque chose de nouveau dans cette
industrie il est nécessaire de remettre
en perspective l'expérience
internationale en la matière le moteur
développé au 19e siècle est un moteur à
pistons
les gens demandent toujours qu'est ce
qu'on peut encore inventé qu'est ce que
vous faites là pendant des jours des
mois des décennies
10-6 comme toute innovation technique
les motor s'adapte aux nouvelles
exigences et technologies
comme vous le savez nous l'avons conçu
en partenariat avec une entreprise bien
connue on entend parfois dire que le
moteur a été emprunté et notre voiture
mais ce n'est pas vrai le moteur a été
développée selon nos critères pour
répondre aux exigences de l'entreprise
aux russes
ce véhicule à un moteur hybride il
produit l'équivalent de 600 chevaux et
la voiture peut passer de 0 à 100 km
heure en 6 secondes en tant que
propriétaires de voitures que peut-on
attendre d'un moteur
l'essentiel est la réactivité
en appuyant sur l'accélérateur
si vous devez ressentir instantanément
ce plaisir pour lequel vous avez jeté ce
véhicule si l'impression de vous
enfoncer dans le siège mais en même
temps vous devez sentir le moteur
lorus est une voiture très sensible
si vous conduisez doucement et calmement
le bruit sera doux et calme
et c'est gratuit en revanche si vous
appuyer sur l'accélérateur
si
vous sentez cette puissance de 600
chevaux et le moteur va vraiment rugir
artistes en devenir gênant
la grande question que posent les
sceptiques à propos de ce véhicule mais
qu'est-ce qu'il a deux russes porsche a
participé au développement du moteur et
certaines de ses pièces sont importés de
l'étranger
sont pas autant que je sache aucun pays
au monde ne fabriquent toutes les pièces
même pour les moteurs sur son propre
territoire
on a posé cette question à rolls royce
est ce qu'il y à d'anglais dans cette
voiture comme lien de pièces sont
produites en angleterre 10% pourquoi
parce que nous voulons que la voiture ne
soit pas seulement anglaise mais aussi
la meilleure
nous aussi nous voulons que notre
voiture soit non seulement russes mais
aussi la meilleure
certaines pièces et assemblage ne
peuvent être fabriqués en russie
mais nous travaillons à cela nous
contactons les entreprises locales ils
examinent le projet nous disent c'est
intéressant nous maîtriserons cette
technologie pour vous
actuellement environ 50 entreprises
russes participent au processus de
production de véhicules aux russes de
moscou à krasnoïarsk
l'entreprise cammas modernise
aujourd'hui sa fonderie et maîtrise des
techniques personne n'avait auparavant
adopté en russie parce qu'à cause d'une
usine de riazor a énormément amélioré la
qualité de son cuir même nos partenaires
occidentaux estiment que la qualité du
cuir russe répond aux standards mondiaux
la concurrence est féroce donc chaque
faux pas est examiné à la loupe en 2011
alors que la limousine de barack obama
quitté le territoire de l'ambassade
américaine à dublin son châssis a heurté
une rampe les agents des services
secrets ont immédiatement déployé une
camionnette sur les lieux bloquant la
vue pour la foule de spectateurs
nous en avons tenu compte et la garde au
sol de notre voiture est d'environ 20 cm
donc cela n'arrivera pas en 2017 la
cadillac de donald trump n'a pu accéder
à la cour d'honneur du palais royal à
bruxelles elle était trop large les
portes et la carrosserie blindée du
véhicule sont trop épaisse trump a dû se
déplacer à pied en violation flagrante
des protocoles de sécurité en 2020 boris
johnson a été impliqué dans un accident
un manifestant s'est précipité sur la
route le véhicule de sécurité n'a pas su
réagir et embouti le coffre de la jaguar
de johnson
les véhicules modernes sont dotés de
systèmes électroniques qui aident les
conducteurs à réagir à toutes les
situations
chaque petit détail est pris en compte
c'est un grand appareil numérique sur
rose la plupart des constructeurs
automobiles dont nous travaillons à
améliorer la sécurité et assurer un plus
grand confort de conduite
pour parler de sécurité divers systèmes
d' aides à la conduite joue maintenant
un rôle énorme lors de certaines
manoeuvres
ces systèmes appelé ads ont été adaptés
aux conditions russes nous avons des
régions du nord où les températures
descendent jusqu'à moins 40 degrés
celsius
même si la route est couverte de neige
c'est à dire dans des conditions
difficiles notre système reconnaît
toujours les objets importants et
indique au conducteur ce qui se trouve
sur la route
tout ingénieur doit éprouver
personnellement ce qu'il construit dès
l'apparition des premiers prototypes de
nombreux essais sur route ont été
effectués
vous avez bien sûr très envie d'appuyer
sur l'accélérateur lorsque vous
conduisez cette voiture mais un de nos
collaborateurs a essayé et s'est écrasé
dans la clôture donc nous avons dû
installer des glissières de sécurité
avant qu'un véhicule puisse prendre la
route il doit passer une série de tests
dans des conditions réalistes c'est à
cela que sert le centre d'essai d'une
amie attend son tour être jugé
techniquement conforme est apte à
prendre la route tout véhicule doit
répondre à 60 critères au moins sécurité
passive visibilité éclairage automobile
sécurité environnementale consommation
de carburant système de freinage et
c'est
le plus important étant la sécurité
active et passive
parce que la vie des usagers en dépend
choc frontal latéral comme vous le savez
les véhicules modernes sont équipés de
systèmes électroniques complexes le
crash test est conçu pour garantir non
pas un niveau minimal de sécurité pour
les usagers mais un niveau de sécurité
bien supérieur c'est terrible de voir un
véhicule s'écraser à pleine vitesse mais
que pouvons nous faire d'autre
il faut s'assurer que les exigences de
certification sont respectées je ne peux
pas donner un chiffre exact mais plus de
mille ajustements et modifications ont
été faits après les tests nous avons des
installations routières spécialisés pour
tester le dérapage pour que la voiture
ne glisse pas et afin d'assurer la
distance de freinage la plus courte
possible
le centre d'essais dispose de quinze
type de revêtement routier
une route pavée a été construite pour
tester la durabilité cette surface
provoque toutes sortes de vibrations
km sur des pavés équivaut à 7 à 20
kilomètres sur une route régulière
donc le coefficient d'amortissement
accéléré site énormes
en raison de son blindage la limousine
du président russe est deux fois plus
lourde que le modèle civil elle pèse 6
tonnes sac
pour la limousine c'est compliqué tout
véhicule présidentiel à tout un éventail
de caractéristiques particulières que
nous ne pouvons pas divulguer quant aux
modèles pour le marché civil il a passé
tous les tests obligatoires sur les
mêmes installations
lorsque la première voiture a été
achevée que tout le monde s'est mis
d'accord sur le titre de voiture que le
chef d'état devait avoir une nouvelle
séance de réflexion a eu lieu en
affirmant qu'un patient au début tout le
monde pensait qu'il serait facile de
trouver un nom et voilà on va se réunir
partager des idées c'est toulouse mais
nous nous sommes demandés comment ça ce
n'est en différentes langues étrangères
longe la chambre a donc avant de choisir
un nom il fallait bien définir la
philosophie de la marque
quel est son objectif est pourquoi at
elle été créée tonga donc après une
longue réflexion on est arrivé à un non
sens éthique il est composé de deux mots
a room qui signifie or et russes
l'abréviation internationale de la
russie nous avons vérifié comment cela
sonne et en 24 langues et ça sonne bien
lors de la conception de l'automobile
nous avions toujours en tête qu'on était
limité dans le temps
et ce délai ne pouvait pas être reporté
plus la date était proche plus le
travail était un temps 108 heures après
soit la menthe à
la date limite était l'inauguration
le moment où le véhicule construit sur
mesure devait être livré au président
j'ai vu des ingénieurs dont les yeux
étinceler d'entousiasme il passait des
nuits dans l'atelier d'assemblage avec
nous
nous sommes restés au travail plusieurs
nuits d'affilée pour accomplir toutes
les tâches
à quelques jours de l'inauguration nous
ne savions pas encore si nous pourrions
livrer la voiture attendait
à
moscou tous les regards sont braqués sur
le centre ville de la capitale russe
dans quelques minutes la cérémonie de
prestation de serment est d'investiture
du président élu vladimir poutine va
commencer
toute cette adrénaline cette
détermination à surmonter un problème
votre cerveau n'a aucun répit
on a laissé libre cours à notre
imagination
et des idées suggérées pour aborder
divers problèmes resteront longtemps
dans nos mémoires
un jour nous raconterons tout ce qui
s'est passé
[Musique]
le jour de l'inauguration alors que la
voiture devait prendre la route pour la
première fois tous leurs amis et est sur
des charbons ardents comme si on
attendait un lancement de fusée s'était
paré avec nous tout ce temps ses efforts
cet argent et cette énergie que nous
avions dépensé et maintenant elle devait
rouler enfin nous sommes rassemblés dans
une grande salle où la cérémonie a été
diffusée
soit eloi j'avais les mains moites
c'était la première fois que tout le
monde pouvait voir le véhicule nous
étions tous inquiets nous craignons les
commentaires du public
à partir de maintenant même les non
initiés ont compris que le président
était monté dans une voiture
inhabituelle dès le 7 mai 2018 le chef
d'état russe recommencera à utiliser une
automobile produite dans son propre pays
quand elle a démarré tout le monde
applaudit
c'était vraiment excitant de voir tout
cela de suivre chaque mouvement
de regarder comment elle roule comment
elle tourne comment l avance
nous étions heureux en constatant que
tout se passait bien
mais ceux qui font que plus c'est la
satisfaction et la fierté que nous avons
ressenti parce que tout le monde a été
témoin de notre succès a vu ce que nous
avons accompli à quoi ça ressemblait
comment la voiture bougeait et commence
à susciter l'admiration chez les gens
aux choses
je ressens un immense sentiment de
fierté la voiture était digne de notre
pays moins bien depuis le moment où
l'objectif a été fixé il a fallu cinq
ans avant son inauguration et sa
présentation publique crée un nouveau
produit à partir de zéro en seulement
cinq ans c'est rapide
[Musique]
nous parlons aux fournisseurs nous
voyons que leur attitude est désormais
totalement différente avant
l'inauguration nous devions leur
demander de travailler avec nous après
l'inauguration beaucoup ont voulu
rejoindre le projet et nous recevons des
lettres avec des demandes de coopération
on constate un changement radical dans
l'attitude de nos partenaires
le 31 mai 2021 la production en série de
véhicules russe a commencé dans la zone
économique spéciale d alabouga au
tatarstan
[Musique]
à la chine ce que nous espérons que la
production en série d'horus renforcera
la présence des voitures rue sur le
marché international
comme vous le savez j'utilise ces
voitures je vais moi même conduite
plusieurs fois c'est vraiment une
excellente voiture de haute qualité qui
répondent à toutes les normes mondiales
la première voiture qui est sortie de la
chaîne de montage était une berline de
luxe lors us senate cette usine produira
également des tout-terrains chez nous
même avec le lancement de la production
en série la proche restera la même chose
dans tous les véhicules de cette classe
sont fabriqués sur mesure et configurée
pour répondre aux exigences
individuelles l'objectif principal du
projet aux russes et d'inspirer
confiance dans notre capacité à créer un
produit remarquable
notre objectif est de porter la capacité
de production à cinq mille véhicules par
an avec diverses modifications vu quatre
accords l'expérience acquise nous a
permis de relever la barre nous avons pu
développer et fabriquer nos propres
voitures haut de gamme et être
compétitif sur ce marché nous devions
montrer que notre industrie automobile
et est suffisamment mature
lorus a été conçu comme un véhicule à
usage du chef d'état pour des visites
officielles mais il est maintenant de
plus en plus utilisés pour des trajets
privés
il faut mettre la ceinture si nous on va
nous mettre une amende
tant qu'on est sûr et bien on réussit
toujours en russie si on veut vraiment
avoir quelque chose on l'aura je crois
que je ne verrai plus de projets comme
celui-ci dans ma vie si l'on se souvient
de la cl par exemple je n'étais pas
encore né et quand il y aura le prochain
peut-être que je ne serai plus là nous
avons créé un produit compétitif une
gamme de produits disponibles en version
blindée et légères elles partagent
toutes une plateforme modulaire unifiée
pointe fois il n'existe peut-être pas de
projets similaires dans le monde
fini
[Musique]